[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN WELLE: Hello, everybody.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
My name is Brian Welle.
I'm in People Operations, and
one of the teams that I lead
is the People
Innovation Lab, where
we happen to know
that social science is
the coolest thing ever.
So it is my sincere pleasure to
welcome Dolly Chugh to Google
to talk about a fantastic
book that she just
wrote called, "How Good
People Fight Bias, The Person
You Mean to Be."
Dolly is a social psychologist.
She's a Professor of
Management at NYU,
and she is writing about things
that so many of us at Google
care desperately
about and articulates
a journey that I feel like
we, as an organization,
are on today.
So it is such a pleasure
to have you here today.
DOLLY CHUGH: It is such
an honor to be here.
Thank you so much ,
everybody, for coming,
especially after a long weekend.
BRIAN WELLE: Well, I have to
start by confessing something.
DOLLY CHUGH: Uh-oh, this
is going to be good.
BRIAN WELLE: I have
been known to say
after reviewing all of the
unconscious bias literature,
helping to put together
trainings and workshops,
and talking to Googlers about
it, at the end of all of this,
I often say, social
scientists have
been great at demonstrating
that we have a problem.
But they have been terrible
at telling us how to fix it,
and I thought that was true
until I read your book.
And you have done
such a wonderful job
at piecing together
narrative across lots
of different studies and taking
the results of those studies
and translating them into
practical advice for those
of us who want to be better.
DOLLY CHUGH: I appreciate that.
Thank you, Brian.
I think part of my
motivation to write this book
was that I'm as confused
as everyone else in trying
to navigate the confusing
space of trying to be as
good a person as I want to be.
And it occurred to
me that there is
some stuff in these dusty,
academic journals that no one
reads, that could be helpful.
And my goal was, a lot of
the research isn't mine,
but I thought I could
curate it, throw mine
in, add some fantastic
stories and interviews,
and bring it to life.
BRIAN WELLE: Well, you
definitely didn't do that.
DOLLY CHUGH: Thank you.
BRIAN WELLE: So I have
so many questions.
We had the chance to have
lunch before and poor Dolly,
she's like, I need to
go to the restroom.
We didn't see her
for a long time,
and I think she was just--
DOLLY CHUGH: Just for a
minute-- just brush my hair.
BRIAN WELLE: Getting a
rest from my questions.
So here are some that I
thought our audience would
like to hear the answers to.
And by the way, we'll have
a Q&A for about 40 minutes,
and then we will open up the
mics to your questions as well.
So first, I want to
start with something
that is so central to your
book, that if you don't
get this concept
and agree with it,
you shouldn't even read
the rest of the book.
DOLLY CHUGH: That's not a
good sales pitch at all.
It's a terrible
sales pitch, Brian.
BRIAN WELLE: Hopefully,
we can all be there.
But I thought we
had to start there,
and that is with the concept
of bounded ethicality.
I'm going to quote
something from your book.
"Bounded ethicality is the
psychology of good-ish people.
Good-ish people are sometimes
good and sometimes not,
sometimes intentionally and
sometimes not, like all of us.
This model of bounded
ethicality challenges
ways of thinking and
talking, in which
you are either a good person
or not, a racist or not,
an unethical human or not.
We argue that this binary notion
is seductive, but misleading
and scientifically inaccurate."
So this seems obvious when it's
spelled out this way, at least
to me.
But what does it
mean to internalize
bounded ethicality
for ourselves,
and why is it so hard to do so?
DOLLY CHUGH: Thank you so much.
So we've got a
really tight corner
that we put ourselves in when we
think about who we want to be.
Research shows that on a
1 to 7 scale, most of us
put the importance of
thinking of ourselves
as a good person above a 6.
It's really important to us,
not like Mother Theresa good,
but just having
an identity where
we think of ourselves
as the kind of person
that we would call
a good person.
Your definition and your
definition and your definition
may be different of
what a good person is.
But whatever your
own definition is,
that is something that
most of us hold dear to us,
and we feel really
threatened when
there's anything that
suggests we're not
hitting that good person
bar, some minimum threshold
of being a good person.
I know I feel that way.
I got an email from
a student telling me
that I had assigned a
sexist reading to class,
and it was a female student.
And I consider
myself a feminist.
I have two daughters.
I am trying hard to
raise them as feminists.
And to get an email like
this feels very threatening.
I'm like, this is,
oh my god, you've
totally threatened
my good person bar,
my good person identity.
But the truth is, when
I reread the reading,
I was like, ooh, that
is a little like, wow.
What is the whole thing about,
like women just love to shop.
There was some stuff in that
article that really should have
caught my eye, but I
had my own blind spots,
that it just went right by me.
And the problem is,
as a good person,
if I have to be in a super
tight corner, where there
is no room for blind spots
and no room for mistakes,
I will not grow
from that mistake.
I will dismiss that
email from that student.
I will not learn from what
she has helped me see.
I will keep assigning
that reading,
because I won't see the
value in her critique.
And as a result, my
desire to be a good person
is going to hold me back
from being a better person.
Our research on
bounded ethicality--
and when I say our
research, I mean our field,
like psychologists for
the last 40 years--
have shown in so
many different ways
that we do have blind spots,
that we do have lapses,
that we do make mistakes.
And we do have unconscious bias.
We are prone to conflicts
of interest outside
of our awareness.
In every one of those
examples, the question
is, for me, are we just
going to deny that,
or are we going to grow from it?
And so what I'm proposing
is, given that the research
on bounded ethicality is clear,
let's break out of that corner,
that super tight, either/or--
either I'm a good person
or I'm not corner--
and give ourselves room to grow.
And what that means is
setting a higher standard.
Being a good-ish person,
instead of a good person,
is someone who doesn't
necessarily make more mistakes,
but they do acknowledge
more mistakes.
They do own more
mistakes, and they
do learn from more
mistakes than someone
who simply is in that
tight good person corner.
BRIAN WELLE: Now, when I read
that portion of your book,
it called to mind
all the ways that we
reinforce the binary in how
we talk about other people.
We will talk about
people as evil,
or this person is
such a great person,
or this person is a criminal.
It's almost like we've created
the boundaries already,
and then you exist within.
And it doesn't lend itself
to a growth mindset,
which you talk a lot about.
DOLLY CHUGH: Exactly.
And that growth mindset is
that work in progress mindset,
as everyone here is familiar,
that we're not either/or good,
we are always getting
better, no matter where
our starting point is.
And one of the things
that I learned the most
from in writing the
book was the people
I interviewed-- some
of whom are icons,
like Joe McNeil of the
Greensboro Four, 1960
Woolworth's lunch
counter sit-ins,
led the sit-in movement, someone
who is truly a civil rights
giant speaking candidly about
his efforts to have a growth
mindset about gay rights.
A really moving story to me
that says, this either/or
binary is going to hold us back.
We have to find the
work in progress inside.
BRIAN WELLE: You use
concepts in your books
that were like seeing
old friends to me,
because they're concepts
that are very important to us
at Google and ones that we have
been doing our own research on
and have found to be
internally important.
So growth mindset
versus a fixed mindset,
which is this notion that
we all have things to learn.
We can all grow.
We can get better.
We should be
incorporating feedback--
is so important to how we
try to engage with our work
and with each other.
There is another concept
of psychological safety,
and that is creating
environments
where it's safe to express
yourself, to admit mistakes,
and to learn.
We have done our own
research on teamwork,
and we found psychological
safety is the number one
predictor of whether teams are
successful in their endeavors.
What I loved about your
book is that you actually
showed a pathway
from growth mindset
to psychological safety,
to fighting bias.
Can you talk about
those connections?
DOLLY CHUGH: Sure.
And this is where I
took the liberties
that you can't take within
science, where in science, we
would have all been
in a very narrow silo.
Carol Dweck is a psychologist.
Her and her colleagues have
done the work on growth mindset.
Amy Edmondson is the
organizational behavior scholar
with psychological safety.
Unconscious bias,
Mahzarin Banaji.
And they're each doing
really deep, deep work
in those areas, along with
their labs and colleagues.
But what that means is
that connecting those
doesn't happen within science.
Those things sit separately
within our journals.
And so what I tried
to do is step outside
of the science a little bit.
I say in the
beginning of the book,
I'm going to step
outside the science,
because I feel like
we don't have time
to wait 50 years
before somebody is
going to actually
run the studies that
connect all those things.
I think we can use our common
sense to see the connections.
Growth mindset on
an individual level,
seeing yourself as a work in
progress, seeing someone--
seeing yourself as someone
who can grow from mistakes,
rather than when you hit an
obstacle and make a mistake,
you shut down, you
cheat, you quit.
That's what happens
in a fixed mindset.
Well, psychological safety is
the same concept in a team.
Do we shut down as a team?
Do we not talk about mistakes?
Do we not verbalize
vulnerability?
Or do we create a
space where we can
talk about, I think
I messed that up, I
think I dropped the ball,
I'm really scared about
what's coming next.
That's growth mindset
to me on a team level.
And I think that then
sets the stage for topics
like unconscious bias.
I think we've gotten to
the point where we believe
the science on unconscious
bias, but it's still
tough to believe that
it might sometimes
leak into our behavior, that
we might sometimes enact harm.
And so that's where that
psychological safety
in a team where you
can talk about it,
growth mindset within
the individual,
sets us up to do the
work on unconscious bias.
The thing that makes me
saddest about the way
the public dialogue has
moved on unconscious bias
is that we sometimes
seem to be saying, well,
because it's unconscious,
I'm no longer accountable.
That's like saying
because I was drunk,
I'm not accountable
for the harm I did
when I was behind the wheel.
Absolutely, you are
still accountable.
The question is,
how are we going
to take ownership and
learn from it, especially
when, as scientists, we have
not cracked the code on how
to debias our brains yet?
So in the meantime,
we're going to have
to use the growth mindset
and psychological safety
as our tools.
BRIAN WELLE: That is
definitely a theme
I saw throughout the
book, which is noticing.
The first step is just
noticing and being aware.
DOLLY CHUGH: Exactly,
being a first class noticer
is a big part of it.
And then starting
to think about,
if we can't debias
the brain, how can we
debias the process, the team,
the system, the structures?
BRIAN WELLE: A story you were
telling me earlier just stuck
with me about being
willing to not
just notice, but to
acknowledge when each of us
has had a stereotype thought
or expressed unconscious bias,
and we made it conscious.
And it had to do with your
work in prisons and people
who were incarcerated.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
you're doing with
prison population,
and how you felt when you first
went into that environment,
and how that affected you?
DOLLY CHUGH: So I've had this
really wonderful opportunity
to get involved with the NYU
Prison Education Program.
And during the year, I
spent working on this book,
I had two priorities.
I took a sabbatical to work with
the Prison Education Program
and to write the book.
And what that meant is, I was
teaching a four college credit
course, really
similar to the one
I teach MBA students at Stern
on leadership, management,
and negotiation skills.
And I was going to do it in
a prison in upstate New York.
And what I realize
now when I look back,
is that one of the traps
I describe in the book--
that I was probably writing that
chapter while I was actually
displaying the behavior--
was, I talk about
the savior trap,
about having this vision of
yourself as being a do-gooder,
who's going to save the day and
have that feel-good feeling,
that warm glow that comes
from saving someone else.
And I can now see how
that was motivating me
into wanting to do the
teaching in prison.
But the problem
with the savior trap
is that it's still
puts me above,
and it otherizes the
people I'm engaging with.
And I saw that in the
first couple of classes
when I was teaching, that I was
super scared of my students,
and I definitely was not
viewing them as individuals.
But within a couple
of classes, it
was weirdly normal
to teach in a prison.
My students were
just-- and I know
there's some alums in the
room-- but they would just
like you guys.
They were funny, and they were
quiet, and they were serious.
And they were more prepared,
and they were less prepared.
They had a whole range
of personalities,
and they were just
individuals who
were super motivated to learn.
Now, do I know that
some of them did things
that created real
harm for people, that
led to them being in prison?
Some of them did.
There is all sorts of injustices
in the system as well.
And is that confusing to me?
And does it create
all sorts of like,
oh my god, the long drives
home from the prison
were real confusing,
mental times for me?
But what I realized
by the third class was
I had dehumanized my students.
I came in thinking, I'm going
to teach a group of felons.
I'm going to redeem them.
And that, in and of itself,
created this savior mentality,
where I was never going
to be useful to them,
because I wasn't seeing
them as human beings.
And so it clicked into
place by class three,
that I had a bunch of
just individuals that I
was going to interact with.
And one of them had read
106 books the year before
and showed me the
list of his books.
And the other one
cried when we role
played difficult
conversations, because he
was thinking about his son.
And they were people.
And now, about
3/4 of my students
have been released from prison.
And when I encounter them and
interact with them in the city
and they're in normal
clothes, I truly
realize that I had created this
image, this uniformed image,
of an imprisoned person that
was absent of any humanity.
BRIAN WELLE: Talking about
prisons in the criminal justice
system, actually brings up
another aspect of your book.
Now, the first
portion of your book
is about taking social science
and helping us understand
how each of us can notice
and change our behaviors,
and to relate to people
and have a growth mindset.
There's another thread
through your book,
which is about systems.
And so sometimes, the
biases that we encounter
are a byproduct of systems
that we've created.
And you talk about this in terms
of headwinds and tailwinds.
I'm wondering, can you tell
me, what do those terms mean,
and is there any research that
you can tell us about that
demonstrates how that happens?
DOLLY CHUGH: Sure.
Absolutely.
So I stole the metaphor
of headwinds and tailwinds
from Debbie Irving.
And she talks
about forces like--
so imagine I'm jogging
so slowly, really slow.
But if I'm jogging and I've
got a good tailwind going,
I might improve my time
from it's usual 10 minute,
30 second mile to a 10
minute, 15 second mile,
because I've got that
tailwind pushing me along.
But I don't get a sense
that I've got a tailwind.
You don't even feel
tailwinds, really.
You just feel like you're
rocking it that morning,
and you're just
like, I don't know,
it was maybe those eggs I ate.
But then when you make
that run and then you
do the U-turn to come back, and
now, you've got the headwind,
you feel every bit of it.
And it does slow you down.
And your time shows it,
and your fatigue shows it,
and your motivation shows it.
That headwind is much
more visible to us
than the tailwind, much
more feelable to us.
And what a systems
approach is about
is, what are the
ways in which we
create very visible headwinds
and less visible tailwinds?
What are the ways those are
built into how we operate?
So when I sent this book
proposal off to publishers,
I literally didn't have
the word system in it.
I didn't have system or systemic
anywhere in the proposal.
I thought this was
going to be a book
purely on the individual
level about unconscious bias.
And it was as I started
talking to people and looking
at the research, that it
became clear to me that,
even if I somehow won the
Nobel Prize and was the one who
figured out how to
debias unconscious bias--
say that was my claim to
fame, wave the magic wand--
I still would not have
solved the problem,
because our systems would still
have so much bias built in.
For example, I used to work in
professional services firms,
like investment
banking and consulting.
And when we would
interview, a big part
of the way we would
interview would be we
would look for fit, cultural
fit, like is this the person
we-- the classic, do you
want to go on a long plane
ride sitting next to them?
Would you want to be
sitting next to them
on a flight to Asia?
Cultural fit.
And I was part of that system.
I interviewed people
using those criteria.
But now, when I look
back and I understand
better how systems
work, I realize
I created a huge
headwind for people
who didn't go to the same
alma mater as me, who didn't
have the same hobbies as me.
Because those were
the kinds of questions
that were the fit conversation.
Could we banter about
common interests?
In fact, Lauren
Rivera, a sociologist,
did an in-depth
ethnography, where
she looked at hiring
practices of elite firms.
And that's exactly
what she found,
was that what we
call fit, that's
meant to capture performance
aspects of a job,
was, in fact, capturing things
like passion hobbies and shared
academic backgrounds, things
that weren't necessarily
tied directly to the job.
That's an example of a
headwind where there's
people from a whole
bunch of schools
who could do the job, who aren't
going to get a chance at it.
There's people who
have varied interests,
who have varied cultural
backgrounds, who have varied
family backgrounds,
who aren't going
to fit the mold of
the kind of banter
that we would do in interviews.
And people like me benefit
from that tailwind,
because I did go
to those schools,
and I do have those hobbies.
I can talk about
marathon running.
I just don't say my time.
BRIAN WELLE: I thought it
was very interesting that you
and your collaborator, Katie
Milkman, took these notions
and applied it to your own
academic community, which,
I think, many
universities, would
like to believe that they are
probably the most egalitarian
institutions you
can be a part of.
But you did a study
that showed otherwise.
DOLLY CHUGH: Katie
Milkman, who's at Wharton,
and Modupe Akinola, who's
at Columbia Business
School, the three of us went
to grad school together.
And a really common
practice before you
apply to a PhD program is--
when I say really common, really
common if you're on the inside
and someone tells you to do
this, so it's not so common--
is to email faculty
at the PhD program
you're interested in and
signal that you're interested
and ask if they'd be willing to
tell you about their research.
And you do all this before
you send your application in,
so it's totally outside the
official formal process.
And all three of
us as grad students
had been advised to do that
by people in our network,
and we did that.
And we did get into grad school,
and we did get great mentors.
And everything worked out
happily ever after for us.
But we were wondering
what happens
to people who aren't
as networked as us
or maybe people who
do get this advice
but don't quite match the
profile that unconsciously
maybe faculty, despite
their egalitarian aims,
might be looking for.
So we did something
kind of sneaky.
It was a sting operation,
which as social scientists,
we call an audit study
or a field experiment.
I know at Google, you are
very familiar with field
experiments.
So what we did was we
created email addresses
using peoples' names.
We pre-tested these names
to either be male-sounding
or female-sounding-- please
forgive the gender binary--
and then white-sounding,
black-sounding,
Hispanic-sounding,
Chinese-sounding,
or Indian-sounding.
So those are five racial
ethnic identities,
two gender identities.
We crossed them.
We have 10 identities now.
We created multiple
names for each identity,
so we don't have any particular
name effect for an identity.
And then we created
an email address
for every one of those
fictional students.
We took the "US News and
World Report" rankings
of the top 260 schools.
For every PhD granting
department in those schools,
we randomly picked the
name of one professor.
And remember, in academia,
all our information
is on the internet.
We're really easy to
find, slash, stalk.
So it was really
easy to do this.
It was a lot of work,
but it was simple.
So now, we've got our
fictional students,
and we've got one professor from
every PhD granting department.
And what we did was we
said, every professor
received one email from
one of those identities.
And our dependent variable
was, would the professor
write back to a cold call
email from a stranger
saying they were
interested in learning more
about this PhD program.
There's a little more nuance
that I'm going to skip.
But if you're ever
interested, we've
got some papers that
get into the details.
But if I cut to
the chase, we were
comparing the
white male identity
to all those not-white male
identities of the students.
And what we found was that, if
you were a white male student,
you had about a 87% chance
of getting a response
to your email.
And if you were not
a white male student,
you had a 62% chance of getting
a response to your email.
And this is identical emails
being sent in identical time
with an identical request.
And so even in our world of
academia where, if anything,
we're stereotyped as being--
you know how we're stereotyped,
like being bleeding
heart liberals--
we were seeing what
I have to assume
was mostly unconscious bias.
There very well is probably
some conscious in there as well,
but I think there was at least
some unconscious bias at work.
BRIAN WELLE: Sobering.
I'd like to shift focus
to work organizations.
So you happen to
be sitting in one.
I'm going to ask you
for some advice here.
You devote a portion
of your writing
to what happens
within organizations,
and for good reason, because we
spend much of our lives here.
And a lot of what we get--
money, status, authority--
comes through work.
So first of all, I found
your definition of diversity
and inclusion very interesting.
So you define each
of them differently.
Let's start with how
you view diversity
and how you view inclusion.
DOLLY CHUGH: Yes, thanks.
And these words
are often bundled
together, diversity and
inclusion, D and I. Sometimes,
you throw in a B for belonging.
But they actually do
mean different things.
And if we're really
to measure success,
we're going to need
to know what we mean.
The metaphor I've been
using for diversity
is, I think of it as
the gateway, the getting
of the job, the getting
into the school, the
getting on the team, the
getting the promotion.
So it's a formal process.
It's often got
some legal guidance
over what appropriate
process is.
It is relatively
easy to measure,
and it sets someone up
to get through the entry
point, the gateway.
Inclusion I think
of as the pathway.
And the pathway is what
leads up to that gateway
and what comes after that
gateway, what comes before it
and what comes after.
So this study I just
described, the audit study,
is an example of
a pathway study.
It was not the formal
application process
into the PhD program.
It was this informal,
if you were in the know,
you sent the email, and it
started this little banter
with a professor.
That is very much
a pathway process.
In pathway processes,
we don't measure.
They're hard to measure.
They can be as fluid
as who interrupts who
at a meeting, who goes
to drinks with who,
who gives eye contact to
who, who sits next to who.
These are the
everyday moments that
can have a real
influence on how people
experience an organization.
But we're not as equipped
to measure them as we go,
and that falls into
the inclusion side.
BRIAN WELLE: So if you think
about inclusion this way,
there are hundreds
of these moments that
occur every single day.
You devote a
portion of your book
on meetings, which
I found fascinating.
So if I work an
8-hour day, it feels
like I spend 10 hours a day.
So that's, I think, the culture
that we have here at Google.
You're very
optimistic, I will say,
throughout your book, which
made it a pleasure to read.
But I think that the title
of this section of your book
was "Meetings Present
Opportunities."
I like that.
I thought it was great.
So if you think about
meetings as opportunities
to be inclusive and to
check your unconscious bias,
what are the tangible
pieces of advice
you would have for all of
us who are spending our days
[INAUDIBLE]?
DOLLY CHUGH: Absolutely.
Thank you for letting
me share that.
The Oktoberfest
conference room that we
were in before we walked
into here, I noticed
had a run inclusive
meetings placard up
there, which was fascinating.
And it mirrored some of
the ideas in the book.
So Tony Prophet is
the chief equality
officer at Salesforce.com, and
I interviewed him for the book.
And when you have a title
like chief equality officer,
I thought, OK, let's find
out what the chief equality
officer recommends.
And I'm expecting
some really big plans.
And I'm sure Tony has big plans.
I'm not in any way
suggesting he doesn't.
But what struck me is
what his first answer was
to my question of, what do
you think is most important?
He said, run better meetings.
I'm like, run better meetings?
Everyone knows meetings suck.
That just part of
organizational life.
And he said, no.
He said, your meetings
mirror your organization.
Whatever the headwinds
and tailwinds
are in your organization are
happening in your meetings.
But your meetings are
a little easier to--
you can get a grip on that.
You can start somewhere.
You can think about, who
should be in the room,
and who isn't in the
room who should be?
You can think about, are
we balancing air time?
That's a measurable thing.
You can think about, did
we interrupt people or not?
we create an environment
in which people disagreed
with each other,
or did we have a meeting--
which I use when I teach
about meetings to my students
in our managerial
skills class, I
call it the most precious real
estate, that we treat meetings
like it's some little piece
of desert land in an area
that nobody wants that land.
They're paying you
to take that land.
That's how we treat meetings.
We just throw them together.
Not here, I mean, like
in other companies.
But the truth is, meetings are
like Fifth Avenue real estate.
Getting multiple people in
the room at the same time,
thinking about the
same thing, that's
Fifth Avenue real estate.
And that's how we
should treat it.
You wouldn't just throw any
old thing on Fifth Avenue.
You would really put a lot
of thought into designing it.
And that's, in fact, what we
do want to do in meetings,
is put that level
of thought into it.
And if you're going to put
that level of thought into it,
and if you're going to use that
level of precious real estate,
what is the point of having a
meeting where everyone agrees
with each other?
Did you actually need
the meeting for everyone
to agree with each
other, or could you
have just agreed to agree
and not have the meeting?
So if you're not
running a meeting where
there is room for disagreement,
then the question is,
why did you have the meeting?
Some of the benefits of
diversity and inclusion
are a range of perspectives,
are a range of opinions.
Is this a meeting where
you can actually do that?
BRIAN WELLE: One of
the dynamics that we
know can happen in meetings is
that people who you would not
expect to have a
legitimate point of view
on any particular
topic are marginalized.
So you can have wonderful
things being expressed
that are simply not heard.
And in the book, you talk about
your dissertation research,
which actually, demonstrated
in a really profound way,
I thought, with some actual
statistics behind it.
Can you tell us, what
was that research,
and what did you find?
DOLLY CHUGH: That takes us back.
So in my dissertation,
here's what I did.
I asked people to
be in a game show,
but it wasn't
really a game show.
It was just me and
my laptop walking
around South Station in
Boston, asking strangers
to play this game with me.
They were different times.
You could do that.
So the game I would
ask them to play
is, I would say, I'm going to
show you photographs, and I
want you to guess how many
jelly beans are in the jar,
or how much this huge
piece of machinery weighs,
questions that would be kind
of hard to know the answer to
without some special knowledge.
And I'm going to pay you
for how well you guess.
The closer you get,
the better you do.
But it's going to be like--
I forget which game show,
is it Hollywood Squares
that does this, where
you first get to guess,
and then you get to listen to
someone else's point of view.
And then you get to
revise your guess.
So the question is,
do you use the advice
that someone else
gives you or not?
The questions were the
same for everybody,
but the thing I varied is
whose advice they heard.
And they would just listen
to it in little headphones.
And so the advice might be
someone with a Hispanic accent.
It might be someone
with a white-sounding--
I realize those are not
mutually exclusive--
but white-sounding accent.
It might be someone who sounds
African American, male, female.
It just had a bunch
of different voices.
And of course, I
rigged the whole thing
so that all the advice
was 100% correct.
So everybody heard
the correct answers,
and it was just a matter of
whether you trusted the advice
from this unknown voice.
And what I found was, I
called it a stereotype tax,
that the people,
for example, who
had a female
advisor in their ear
were less likely to
take that advice.
I think they made--
BRIAN WELLE: $0.69.
DOLLY CHUGH: $0.69 on
the dollar for people
who had a male
advisor, because they
were so much less likely
to take the advice
of the female advisor.
And I tried to standardize
a whole bunch of things,
like the tone of the
voice and everything that
would make something
sound different, other
than just the gender.
And so the
dissertation, the idea
there was to show, even in
these really fluid moments,
like in meetings, for
example, when somebody throws
an idea out, and we have to
make that split second of,
do we keep going with
that, or do we move on?
Those little, quick
moments, we are potentially
discounting points of view.
BRIAN WELLE: And
I know it can be
difficult to counteract that.
If there were an
easy solution, we
would implement it right
now, and all the meetings
would be amazing.
And you would take
all points of view
into account that were
good points of view.
Maybe I demonstrated
it's problematic
thinking right there.
In your book, you are
prescriptive about things
that we can do.
One of the things
that I noted was for--
if you walk into a setting and
you have ordinary privilege,
you are walking in
with a stereotype
that operates on your behalf.
And you are a
person with a growth
mindset, someone who is on
the journey to being a better
person.
And you hear ideas using
your ordinary privilege
to stand up for
someone else's idea,
was one way of doing that.
DOLLY CHUGH: Exactly.
Amplified.
BRIAN WELLE: Any
other tangible advice
to help us really
hear good ideas?
DOLLY CHUGH: I also, sometimes,
do the thought experiment
in my head, of when I can feel
myself dismissing someone,
I imagine the same idea
coming out of someone else.
I'm not going to say
who, but right now, I'm
picturing two colleagues in
my mind in my work world.
And if I take the idea
out of one person's mouth
and I put it in another, would
I be listening more carefully,
or would I be tuning out
in the meeting right now?
And the truth is, with the
two people I have in mind,
I might be tuning out less if
it was coming from someone else.
And so I think, while it's
hard to debias the brain,
it isn't so hard
to do the noticing,
to actually just put yourself
in that counter-factual of, what
if?
BRIAN WELLE: I'm going to
ask you another question,
but I will take audience
questions in just a minute.
So if you have one,
there are two mics
and please make
your way up there,
and you can ask your question.
So what you've
described in your book
is a process that we
can all go through.
And many people are engaged in
that journey, but many are not.
And based on some research
that you had reviewed,
you summed up three kinds
of people, the 20/60/20s.
You've got the easy 20s.
These are people who
are intrinsically
motivated to be unbiased.
They are really working.
And you know you
can talk to them,
and you'll have kindred spirit.
Then you've got this middle
60, who's really nowhere.
They're silent.
They're not really
paying attention,
and these issues just have
not surfaced for them yet.
And then you've
got the stuck 20.
This is a 20% of people who
are really set and entrenched
in their ideas.
They are not willing
to listen or to change,
and, I think, we all
probably have some people
like that in our lives.
The thing that
struck me about that
is your advice for
the stuck 20 is,
you can choose to engage
or not engage with them.
It's important to make
your points of view known,
but don't expect,
necessarily, that they're
going to change along the way.
It's an agreement that you come
to with yourself and with them.
In a workplace,
that's problematic,
because let's presume that
a portion of those 20%
are working here with us.
We are in an organization that
is trying very hard to have
bias-free systems and
processes, to hold ourselves up
to higher standards,
to make sure we all
have growth mindsets.
What advice do you have
for organizations that have
portions of these 20% in there?
And we want them to
thrive and add value,
but we also need
them to be operating
in a way that is living up to
the cultural standard we're
trying to set.
DOLLY CHUGH: Absolutely.
So the 20/60/20 rule can
be applied to anything.
It's not specific to bias.
In fact, I learned it
from organizational change
consultant, Susan Nunzio,
who I used to work with.
Academia is a second career.
Consulting, banking
was first career.
And when I worked with her, she
would use this as an approach
to any cultural change
in an organization.
And the 20/60/20,
what it does is not
say that we have to
forget about the stuck 20,
but it does say to be
really careful of how
you use your energy there.
Because the stuck 20 tends to
be vocal, and the middle 60
tends to be quiet.
And so what we can
easily have happen
is that all of our energy and
focus goes to the stuck 20.
And you find yourself
in those arguments
that nobody's listening to,
but you're doubling down,
and they're doubling down.
And the middle 60 is
tuning out, because this
has gotten pretty boring.
And you've missed
the opportunity
to either engage
with the stuck 20,
knowing you have a hidden
audience in the middle 60.
So if you're going
to engage here,
at least know the middle 60 is
listening or could be listening
if you could be engaging.
So rather than it being, you're
trying to convince this person,
think of it as, I'm trying to
actually shape a larger group's
perspective.
And in doing that, you
are going to shift norms.
So when you move the middle 60--
which could go this way or it
could go this way--
you're shaping the norms.
And those norms are going to
do the work on your stuck 20.
Norms are incredibly
powerful shapers of behavior.
And so you may not be able
to convince the stuck 20,
but you are able to
shape norms and influence
the views of people around you.
And that will do the work.
That's a powerful lever.
BRIAN WELLE: I found it amazing
to read about how you interact
over social media
with people who had
very contrarian points of view.
And you write that you will
engage with them, knowing
that the 60% are reading.
So you're really engaging
them for the 60%,
and not with any expectation
of changing the person you're
exactly [INAUDIBLE].
DOLLY CHUGH: Exactly.
I know when I'm not
going to get anywhere
in one of those
social media things
that we all find ourselves in.
But what I do do is speak to
the lurkers, because I know--
because I lurk, too--
I know there's a whole bunch
of people lurking and waiting
for the fight to begin.
And instead of
going into the fight
now that I've got
their attention,
I just use it as an
opportunity to speak.
And sometimes, I literally
just speak past the person
arguing with me.
I'm respectful.
I'm always respectful,
but I don't even
worry about getting into
what they're saying.
I just say what I wish the
middle 60 knew and use it
as that moment now that
I've got the fight--
their attention on the fight.
BRIAN WELLE: There
was a powerful moment
in your interview
with Joe McNeil.
And you had asked him
whether, in hindsight,
he would have done anything
differently when he was sitting
at that counter at Woolworth's.
DOLLY CHUGH: Exactly.
Joe McNeil, Greensboro Four,
who we talked about earlier.
First I asked him, would
you have done anything
differently looking back?
He's in his mid-70s now.
At first, he's like, no,
I think we did it right.
And then he took a sip of
his coffee, and then he said,
you know what I would have done?
I would have spoken more to
the people who were silent.
Basically, he was
saying the middle 60.
I would have given them a chance
to be a better person, too.
That's what I would have done.
And I just thought that
was such a powerful insight
from somebody who was
really on the front lines
risking everything,
his life, everything.
BRIAN WELLE: Any
questions from any of you?
I've got more.
DOLLY CHUGH: Good.
BRIAN WELLE: So
the growth mindset
that you described
in the book will
lead us to ask a lot more
questions than we're probably
asking today.
It will lead us to take
seriously the things
that people tell us, that
we may have dismissed,
our old self may have dismissed.
But the new self is
actually reflecting on it,
seeing if there's
some truth to it.
In the process of having
this growth mindset
and being on this
journey, you're
asking the people who may
be most disadvantaged, most
marginalized, the ones who
are the negative recipients
of the unconscious bias, to do
a lot of educating and engaging.
Is that fair?
DOLLY CHUGH: I don't want to
put that burden of education--
so this is where those of us
who have ordinary privilege--
ordinary privilege is the
piece of your identity
you think least about.
We all have multiple
facets for identity.
I'm straight.
I can go weeks and months
without thinking about the fact
that I'm straight.
The world is set up for me.
Someone asked what
I did this weekend.
It's easy to just
share, my husband
and I did this or whatever.
I can put pictures
of my family, and I
don't worry about
being penalized
in some conscious or
unconscious way at work.
Ordinary privilege is a
piece of your identity
you think least
about, because that's
where you have the tailwinds.
And that's also where you
have surprising influence.
And so studies show
that, let's say,
a black person says
something about a racist joke
versus a white person
saying something
about the same racist joke.
The black person is
perceived as being whiny,
whereas the white person
will have more influence
than they expect they're
going to have in that moment.
There's been multiple
studies that have basically
shown that same pattern.
That in the piece
of your identity
where you have ordinary
privilege, what
ordinary privilege brings
is unexpected influence.
And so this is where so many
of us feel helpless right now.
We actually have reason
to be optimistic,
that we have more
influence than we realize,
not to speak over
or for someone else,
but to take some ownership,
so that the same people aren't
doing the same work educating
others time and time again.
The other thing
I really liked is
I interviewed Subha Barry, who's
held a number of senior roles
in financial
services and is now,
I think, the President
of Working Mother Media.
And she's been fighting a
bunch of fights for decades,
trying to create more equity
and equality in organizations.
And I asked her how she
sustains herself in that.
And she described flipping
channels on the TV
once and running across
this "National Geographic"
special about birds.
And it was all about
the V-formation
that some birds fly in.
Have you ever noticed that?
And what she did know, and I
didn't know till she told me,
is that when you see that
V-formation in the sky
and it looks like
it's just static,
the same birds, that
what's actually happening
is the lead bird
rotates to the back.
There's this constant
rotation, and that's
because the lead bird is the
one who's taking the headwinds.
That's the hardest job, to
break the wind up front,
and it's the most exhausting.
So the way the birds
are able to sustain this
is by not always having
the same lead bird.
And I think that's
another piece of this.
In the areas in which we
have ordinary privilege,
how can we step into
that lead bird role,
again, not speaking
over or for people,
but taking some
ownership for trying
to create the kind of
environment, culture, workplace
that we value?
AUDIENCE: Hi, professor.
So in your amazing
class at Stern,
you taught us that
there were a lot
of different types of cultures
that could be successful.
But building off
the conversation
about bias and hiring
practices, how do you
have a hiring practice that gets
the right person for culture
without culture fit being
synonymous for some sort
of implicit bias in that?
DOLLY CHUGH: Absolutely.
So I think it's a matter
of thinking about what
it is about that
cultural fit that's
going to enhance performance
and actually getting into what
the behavioral indicators are.
So if what's needed
is that we need
to be able to spend
long periods of time
together without driving
each other crazy,
we can do that
without necessarily
having to have gone to the
same cluster of colleges.
It's more a matter of maybe
what you do in your interviewing
or hiring process--
is you actually
screen for, what is
it like to spend time
with this person,
or how do they
react under stress,
as opposed to relying on the
more informal banter that makes
assumptions that, just because
we went to the same schools,
we would have the
same comfort level.
And I realize it's
not that explicit.
The processes I was
part of and advanced,
we were never that
explicit that we were
looking for the same schools.
But that is what
we ended up doing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DOLLY CHUGH: Thank you.
Nice to see you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming here and
having this conversation.
DOLLY CHUGH: Thank
you for having me.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
what your advice is
for when you make a mistake,
particularly in the workplace,
how do you recover from that?
How do make sure you repair
the harm that you've done,
and how does that work?
DOLLY CHUGH: Absolutely.
So I think it's like in
all other parts of our life
when we have some sort
of faux pas or error
that creates negative
impact on others.
The ways in which we know,
taking accountability,
works here, too.
So we'll use an example.
It's not, I'm sorry you
were offended by that.
It's, I'm sorry that I did harm.
I'm sorry for my
error in judgment.
I'm sorry for my ignorance.
And then where you
can go with that is,
you can ask if the other person
is interested in educating you
about the harm you've done.
But you don't expect
them to do it,
because that is putting
labor on the other person
to then go through-- not
only has harm been done,
now it's my job to educate
you about your blind spots
and deal with all your
emotional reactions
and not offending you and
all that sort of stuff.
So I think it's
first the apology.
You can make an invitation.
If the person is into it, great.
If they're not, it's
your job to go figure
out how to educate yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DOLLY CHUGH: Thank you.
BRIAN WELLE: In your
book, you read a bit
about traumatic events that have
been happening in the United
States, whether it's
the shooting in Orlando
at a gay nightclub or the police
shootings that have happened.
And we know people who are
members of the communities that
would have been affected.
And you profiled
different people
and how they've
processed that, or how
they've provided support.
What is a lesson that
you learned from them
that you would pass on to us?
DOLLY CHUGH: So psychologists
call this hidden grief.
That at any given
moment, including now,
one out of four of
us is sitting here
in this room with
real hidden grief,
whether it's the
loss of a loved one,
whether it's a traumatic
event in your life,
whether it's something
happening in the news that
feels very personal to you.
There's a lot of work you're
doing just to hold it together
at any given moment.
And in what I read about and
learned about with hidden grief
and thinking about it in the
context of national events
and international events
and how they affect,
for example, my students--
I teach at NYU.
I deal with students on--
not on a daily basis,
but on a flowing basis
where I see them over the
stretch of an entire semester.
And things happen in the
world during that time.
And it used to be that just
if I didn't know what to say,
I'd say nothing.
And I have to confess
that there's still
a portion of times when
that's exactly what happens.
But I think what I learned from
the hidden grief research was
just the noticing that
someone's grief is there
and the acknowledging that
you see it, the bearing
witness of it-- not inserting
myself, not making myself
the savior, not
cookie-seeking, meaning,
cookie-seeking is like looking
for their validation of how
awesome it was that
I checked in on them.
But just saying, hey,
how are you holding up?
And that's actually
a phrase that I
learned from one of my
former students, the,
how are you holding up?
It allows the other person to
go in any number of directions.
They can say, oh my
god, I'm falling apart,
I need to tell you everything.
Or they can be like, oh
good, everything's great.
They can use that question
to go as deep or as
lightly as they want, but
they know that they're seen.
And so I think the
hidden grief piece
is one of the places
where I'm trying
to do the most work,
of figuring out
how to not allow silence to look
like indifference to others.
And that is how it's often
perceived in the workplace.
Should I go there?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
First of all, I wanted to
say, Brian, thank you so much.
You ran the unbiasing video.
I'm a new-gler, so I
saw an hour and a half
of unbiasing training.
And now, I'm having a
little Google crush.
You're doing a great job.
DOLLY CHUGH: That's so sweet.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for putting
together these programs.
I'm definitely part
of the 20% here,
in part, because I want
to be a better person,
and I want to be
a better coworker.
And I'm a sociologist,
so I'm constantly
thinking about the group
and the systematic biases.
And I think being
at Google has really
challenged me to see where I
fit at the individual level
and really what's
going on there.
And you said, changing
the unconscious bias
using our brain is really
hard and then you move on.
And I want to open
that up a little bit.
What is it that I
could do or anybody
could do to really
push ourselves
to find the blind spots.
Because naturally, our brain
doesn't want to find them.
How do we push
ourselves to become
more comfortable
with these truths
that maybe we didn't want
to acknowledge before?
Are there exercises?
Are there great podcasts?
Well, there might be.
I don't know.
DOLLY CHUGH: There might be.
AUDIENCE: So any thoughts
there would be great.
DOLLY CHUGH: Absolutely.
Thank you.
You may have already
done this, but I'll just
throw out ideas for everyone.
So there's the Implicit
Association Test,
which is called the IAT.
Would they have done that
through the training?
BRIAN WELLE: Possibly.
It's mentioned.
DOLLY CHUGH: So
implicit.harvard.edu
is the site where
you can find it.
You can do it
completely anonymously.
It's about a 10 minute
test on the internet.
It is not a perfect test.
It is an in-progress scientific
method that we are trying
to improve--
we, meaning, we the field.
But it will give you a sense
of where your blind spots are.
You can pick different topics.
There's at least 20 tests up
there, race, gender, skin tone,
physical ability.
It goes on and on, sexual
orientation, religion.
So that's one place to start.
The second thing
you can do, there's
a great story in the book about
Rick Klau, who some of you
may know at Google Ventures, who
I met at the same conference I
met you at, Brian, at the Rework
Conference a few years ago.
BRIAN WELLE: When
you wrote in the book
that there was that moment
of awkwardness when you were
trying to get your taxi back.
It made me feel bad.
DOLLY CHUGH: It
made you feel bad?
BRIAN WELLE: I was
like, Dolly, I'm
so glad you didn't get your
taxi to go back to the airport,
and you came back.
DOLLY CHUGH: I was
just saying, they
had the opening dinner
for the conference.
And you know when you
arrive at something,
and there's going to be
that networking thing.
And you get there, and
there's that moment
where you have
nobody to talk to,
and you're just standing there.
And I just wanted to run
and get my taxi back.
I could still see it out
of the corner of my eye.
And then Rick Klau saved the
day and said, hi, I'm Rick.
So I ended up having what
would have been a small talky
conversation at the
entrance of what
was a fantastic conference
in every way with Rick Klau.
And one of the things
he talked about
was after he took the IAT,
he got a gender result
that he wasn't happy with.
It didn't match his
perception of himself as--
I'm putting this in
quotes, because he
cringes every time I say it--
as one of the "good
guys," meaning someone
who hires women, promotes
women, creates opportunities
for under-represented groups.
He really saw
himself as the person
who didn't need the
unconscious bias training, who
didn't need to take the IAT.
And then when he got the
result, he was taken aback.
And he thought,
well, I don't know,
I don't think that's true.
He's very active
on social media.
And I think in his particular
role at Google Ventures,
social media is a really
important part of the platform
and influence he has.
So he's like, I don't know
what they're talking about.
And he starts going through
and running some algorithms
on who he follows on
LinkedIn, on Twitter,
who he retweets, who
he's connected with,
things like that.
And he kept getting that
his network was 80% male,
and this was not what
he expected at all.
And it was consistent
across all the platforms.
Then he started
noticing on his calendar
that he'd been sitting on
all-male panels, again,
an important place where
his voice and platform have
influence.
And so he realized through
this little self audit he did--
and so that would be the
second thing I would suggest,
is a self audit.
In his case, he felt like this
network was an important place.
For you, it might be,
who are the last 10
people you had coffee chats
with to network about--
I'm sure you all have friends
who want to work at Google.
Who are the people
that you're having
those informal
conversations with?
If you're a big movie
person or book person,
what are the last 10 books
or movies you consumed?
How different were the
voices and experiences
in those books and
movies from your own,
versus how similar were
they to each other?
We're not just dealing with
our implicit associations
that we've built over
our lives until now.
We're creating new
ones right now.
Which ones are you
creating right now?
Those are things we
can actively change.
You can change who's
in your network.
You can change what
you're consuming, what
you're feeding your brain with.
I think those are immediate
steps we can take,
where we don't have to do the
bigger work of systemic change.
Thank you for your question.
BRIAN WELLE: We're coming
at the end of time.
Dolly, thank you so much for
spending time with us today.
As our new-gler mentioned,
we have an unconscious bias
curriculum.
All new hires are invited
to watch this video
to learn about it.
And we'll get e-mails
every single week
after the video goes out.
And the most common email
is, I want to learn more,
and I want to know
what I can do.
And from this point forward, I'm
going to say, read your book,
because there's a lot of
practical advice there.
So thank you for
sharing it with us.
DOLLY CHUGH: I have
such a crush on you.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you so much, Brian.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]